hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to there's poop in my soup a
really silly game that I found on
gamejolt that's probably a lot like
money Heights I really don't know I
haven't played yet
um but if you've noticed obviously there
is no reading your comments video I'm
very sorry for that it's been a crazy
busy weekend one with the charity
livestream that I joined for the game
grumps on Saturday and then playing
catch-up yesterday and then also we've
been cleaning the house all weekend
because Daniels family is actually
coming in today by the time you're
watching it so they should be here and
we're gonna take them around LA and
we're gonna show them a good time and
then you know try to try to make their
stay fun and enjoyable as we can but
until then I'm gonna play a stupid game
about poop and you'd be shocked at how
many poop games there are not that I
went looking for poop games but mostly
my back guy I have a to pool list oh god
oh god I don't want to get a bomb poo I
don't know what a bomb poo is oh what's
with these people I just kind of
realized that these are horrifying
monstrosity 'z that aren't exactly
people what what was that oh huh
oh I thought I was floating in mystic
for a second there yeah
I'm charging up my poo what I'm trying
to I'm like I'm taking a moment to score
of zero oh good I didn't pull on anybody
that seems like a win in my book oh my
goodness okay so ah the beam of light is
not where I was it's where I'm pooping
and somehow all just pooping backs oh my
god did he die oh he broke his long neck
what was that not possible oh my
goodness
yay oh now the music kicks in now the
party started now that the poo starts
flying everybody's having a good time
it's got a [ __ ] l-- who Brella laughs
odd dammit
who on the bait oh I don't want to poo
on the baby I mean absolutely yes I'm
gonna do that but oh that's so mean I
mean babies are natural pool machines
anyway so
that's right oh my god it's so immature
I mean there's a guy dead on the street
I don't know why more people aren't
exactly panicking about it oh all right
then
I knocked four or five things off my
poopoo list I gotta get the baby and the
mommy and one okay that's another one
off the tapu list oh boy
mohawk man you're getting pooed on for
some reason is a pastime of everybody
involved oh wow the more people you put
on the laughter the music gets oh oh
he's dead
you're gonna be dead knocking over these
Kansas 100 my combo you broke my boob oh
my my comp ooh never mind
oh I just noticed my character has a
butthole on the front of his face well
that explains a lot I suppose okay I'm
gonna get him with my last pool I do
fling at thee yes I got it
that was another tapu list I'm doing
well okay I got to bounce it into the
bin okay so I got to bounce it in the
bin hey wink get out of the way my poo
I'm trying to get in the waste bin I'm
trying to be a responsible poor every
buddy but you seem to be very very eager
to catch my poo going dying I'm not
responsible for all of these deaths you
know I'm not gonna be labeled to murder
just because I'm rampantly booing off of
me up that baby caught a faceful that's
no good yeah okay that's one that's
another on the tapu list so I need a
three times in the bin I can do that
because I'm responsible yeah yep
can I just pop into the bend over and
over
[ __ ] under my umbrella so how do I get
her when she's under the umbrella I'll
hit the cans you got it
yeah 420 poison my windows over my
neighbors have been his whole time
stream about poof crap
well that was embarrassing all right we
only get a few left I got a poo bomb aah
oh god no oh oh Mike you gotta get this
six times combo oh wait yeah no cheese
it's like an avalanche of poo I think I
have a digestion aproblem if this is
actually what's going on I got it in the
box
jeez get out of the way thank you
now I gotta bounce it in the box because
I'm very particular about my
achievements in life oh I already did it
never mind then and get 50 people I'm
pretty sure with my poo bond this is
gonna be pretty easy a little kid
looking at his ice cream so sad oh well
that's silence whoa so much poo so much
poop äj-- whoa 15,000 425 it's a big
upgrade from just 420 blaze it good god
it's literally a puss I've done
everything else I could do
I guess that's the end of it then good
god so anyway that's there's poo in my
soup so thank you everybody so much for
watching uh I apologize that I don't
have enough time in the schedule has
been slightly wonky I tried to do three
videos yesterday and that just kind of
threw my schedule off way further but
hopefully starting tomorrow everything
will be back on schedule
I'll get reading your comments out as
soon as I can uh and we're gonna have a
fun time hanging around with the kyer
family and then both Matt and Ryan
significant others are here as well so
it's gonna be a very crowded house but
thank you everybody so much for watching
and thank you for the patience and thank
you for enjoying the pool game if you
want play for yourself
links in the description as well as our
other two related videos thanks again
and as always I'll see you in the next
video